[Music]
so who's got their stimulus payments how
does it happen do you have to sign up or
no no no it depends on your income how
do they know this the IRS right like
they just have files on everyone they
just know and they just send you money
yeah I think it's just based off of like
your taxes oh I didn't get free money
I'm into to ballin oh yeah you are to
ballin how ballin are you though you
didn't get a stimulant payment Julia
give me some fun thank you that's not
fair so and why did we do it within a
check it was an actual stimulus direct
deposit it depends on on how you follow
your taxes yeah so like I got a check-in
but I know a lot of people got direct
deposit Oh interesting
and apparently some people are getting
something that looks like this
American flat car I didn't get that
that's so sick yeah so it's a it's a
prepaid debit card with whatever the
money that's in there right and a lot is
that real and that's the problem a lot
of people are like looking at this like
it doesn't seem like it's official it
looks kind of like you know janky or
whatever we were throwing these shits
away there's no one announced that
that's how they were gonna send them out
though yeah exactly we don't know what
to expect I'm like that's why I'm asking
you like was it a check was it like you
put valued customer on it and I think
it's a [ __ ] scam alright cuz you get
those those credit cards we qualified
yeah how am i exactly what they're
mistaking it for this is what your card
can look like whoa well then if it has a
chip on there then that should be
official right I wouldn't see it as that
cuz it might be a fake doesn't say my
name on it
true true but yeah so a lot of people
are throwing these away Oh
ready let's go check in our man I mean
in the trash yeah I'm like and I think
I'm like I should be oh look at all the
trash Fred throw it away YouTube gave us
a debit card when we went to Korea and
it said YouTube creator on it I still
have it somewhere always you know he's
got stuff somewhere I have it somewhere
but I I thought it was so cool that they
printed out a card that we could just
use for food or
whatever we want and it says I'm
creating weight YouTube created Evelyn I
don't remember but I slept spending it
and I still had like 30 bucks on it it
was dope it was like I think they gave
us like a grin or something it was a lot
yeah two grand to use for the two weeks
that were there and then they're like if
you need more money let us know and
we'll load more into it I would say
immediately yeah we ran out of money
yeah I mean but we just kept getting
drinks and whatever and but at the same
time like I didn't even need it because
they kept feeding us and everything was
taken care of so I didn't have time to
spend it and then like yeah I checked I
went back home and I'd like 30 bucks
don't want it I don't know I felt like
thanks you too yeah that was really felt
love there you know threw money in Korea
in Korea what I like about Asia is that
they've they've been using like the
prepaid cards or like you know like mass
transit or whatever like they don't they
don't [ __ ] use cash or anything and
I'm like not even like credit cards they
have like these special like passes
where you just beep into every store you
go to send like we just beep your way
out and you're able to pay it's all
connected this little like card thing
makes it more convenient yeah you ride
the train with it you do it everything
the multi-purpose card like a multipass
yeah I love her
yes who is this the fulfillment
multipass organize yeah that's the
costume of the a resident yo check her I
was at a premiere with her one time
she's the second hottest chick I know
really who's the hottest chick you know
say something real have you seen her
hands the camera a little bit yeah yeah
comedy dude oh they're [ __ ] it's like
Mickey Mouse gloves thank you right for
my shoulders to call me fats and all the
hens
I never said your face yeah you did you
said I gained a little weight I'm like
oh I said you can't weighting your
shoulders I never said you came here
called me fat I never said that
shoulders that's pretty good cellulite
beautiful fat it's not my kind of [ __ ]
cellulite shoulders unless they're not
here but yeah so if you guys get this
and then I'm talking you guys out there
if you guys get this weird looking debit
card that's a valued valued card at to
to choke that the Joe exactly but it
should be in an envelope that says it's
from the Treasury secretary or whatever
or whatever Treasury Department yes and
if you're ever in doubt just there's
there's usually a website or phone
number you can call just to like look
like or read the letter that it came in
I just want to read man I'd [ __ ]
chuck this [ __ ] you noticed though junk
mail hasn't been coming in that much yes
it has yeah it has I'm I barely don't
get yeah I do
look at this guy he has one experience
he thinks everyone having the same his
face or weeks now we talked about them
get the coupons anymore I get it all I
get too much of it I get [ __ ] blind
[ __ ] and I already have blinds yeah I
think my area they gave up I think they
gave up really you're moving into a new
house like the [ __ ] spam you with
like house buying show me already
[ __ ] pop my house yeah you want to
buy another one yeah what one of them
that was really clever that I liked is
so our front yard is done alright but
this guy he I guess they do turf so he
he just left a piece of like fake turf
with his business card stapled on it and
you just threw it on everyone's front
yard it's met its memory it is expensive
but it's memorable so we just took it in
now tightness plays with this little
square of I get Wienerschnitzel coupons
those are good and I'm like I haven't
eaten here in [ __ ] 15 years I'll take
it alright
you don't like corn bong oh very good
corn dogs really good what makes it so
special with the [ __ ] corn dog it's
crunchy it's like the perfect like a
little bit of sweetness yeah it's so
good how come they gonna give away so
many coupons because people forget they
forget about them because you don't
really see them on TV anymore I never
went to an actual location I've always
had it like at a school lunch
yeah well rich school did you go to oh
no you know what else people forget
about people forget about the things
they asked for you know did you know
that Gio begged me to roast her [ __ ]
almost yeah and I loved it I'm not going
okay but I know but you you asked me of
course and I'm happy but but for you
that could be no but for a year RBF bro
oh you're not I couldn't find an angle
on Gio you still can
no I got the hand Stanley it's neither
the shoulders neck shoulders what's the
next thing but those aren't even real
enjoyed it well I know it's not even an
insecurity I did a roast at least
finally but it's not a good one
Wow I'll do better on the table you're
breaking with the big hands I didn't see
Bart's face honestly doing well no this
is like a lot of shadows
but yeah so for those of you guys that
have thrown it away have no fear you can
always get a replacement by calling
customer service at
[Laughter]
for me I think I would hire a nerd and
we will get some hacker [ __ ] going on
because like I don't think I'll go
inside where guns blazing not very
cinematic I was hoping you'd ease your
feet hackers are so cinematic what about
the movie hackers but I mean imagine the
movie trailer for a hacker bank heist
messed the whole movie imagine a [ __ ]
swordfish you get your dick suck while
you're hacking it ok that's pretty cool
you got a dick sucking just sort of fish
is it good well also why is there only a
guy hacker why can't we have a female
beauty okay you've never seen hackers
the movie Oh Angelina Jolie yeah she's
hot as [ __ ] I have it was it a good
movie I don't know I don't care I saw
her i just saw the nudie scenes okay you
know who else is a female hacker it's a
[ __ ] Dragon Tattoo chick she tattoo
Rooney Mara Rooney Mara I like her a lot
he's a gorgeous Shido cheap piece she's
wonderful some say peas ass I don't like
that kind of language
wait what are we oh the stimulus thing
yeah I thought you wanted me to talk
about bank robbery I did but I was
hoping you'd use your feet but you did
it so it's okay that's a whole reference
but it's a funny one honey let's
brainstorm because I really want to
steal now so you know I mean you have to
have a mass now I would impersonate Bob
Iger the former CEO of Disney and I just
go to the bank dressed up and he likes
to wear these [ __ ] robe looking Hugh
Hefner ish things for some reason might
as well just do Hugh Hefner no one knows
who the [ __ ] Bob Iger he died but all I
would do is go like hello my name is Bob
Meyer I would like to make it withdrawal
no but I oh sure yeah see that's why Bob
iger's the CEO at this near the previous
CEO Disney that's the [ __ ] I would it
with their life man you [ __ ] up Star
Wars dude ha ha I know I know I can we
make that withdrawal quick hey it's the
guy that [ __ ] up Star Wars and chase
Bay comes out make everybody like oh
you're that guy
[ __ ] sorry I'm sorry but it is George
Lucas did a good job on snow it's the
biggest this is used to work at a bank
what's the biggest withdrawal you've
ever seen oh man I don't even know
anything make it go oh my god uh yeah
because now then you have that multiple
managers like sign off on this thing and
then you're all speaking of checking I
gotta pulls up like do they do more like
thumbprint Dino whale it's a lot of
security like we used to have EDC bank
with us EDC yeah EDC the mom yes and
then so if they wanted to like pay like
big people it would have to be days for
[ __ ] to clear and like they would have
to give like it would be like three to
four days like they did we did a bunch
of background checks and it's out of the
the [ __ ] floor level people say oh I
can't go in and be like I would like to
withdraw ten million dollars cuz I'm
gonna do a bathtub cash video cuz I'm
just thinking about mr. pieces like
conversations there's what the thing
it's gotta be nuts cuz you know how he
has a pallet full of like what like a
million dollars and you're like last one
to leave through here and gets it and
then so I'm like how you [ __ ] get that
much cash yeah hope that wasn't just
hate directed at mr. Bies what you just
didn't I love mr. beast
give me two he's the Beast is of the
beast is there security on his set so he
makes these videos it's a lot of [ __ ]
that's a really good point okay and then
you don't see security he's probably
watching like oh good idea
change I just met these people can you
imagine being so your whole thing is
charity right so like you're gonna
attract a ton of people in his DM every
[ __ ] day asking him for money
yeah I think that's all it is well and
imagine just meeting mr. beast and bees
about to change your life and he's just
there to like get a [ __ ] an oil
change or something I know
oh my god I can't believe you're here
okay hold on a second like my hair's
alright am I gonna get a car yeah he's
on no no we're not filming anything that
would change my timing belt
yeah sorry no the serpentine belts all
[ __ ] I guess
[Music]